[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
MICHAEL SIPSER: Hi, everybody.
Glad to have you all
back for our next
to last installment of
theory of computation.
Today, we are going to embark
on the very last big topic
for the semester, and
that is, in some ways,
going to be following on what
we started a couple of lectures
back when we looked at
probabilistic Turing
machines and probabilistic
computation and its associated
class BPP.
Now what we're going to
discuss is, in some sense,
a probabilistic version of NP.
And that's going
to be a complexity
class called IP, which stands
for Interactive Proof systems.
And so we're going
to present that model
and look at a
couple of examples.
I would just like to
say at the beginning
that this model is a
very important one.
It really has been
the starting point
for a great deal of research
in complexity theory.
So we're just really going
to be touching on it,
but there's a lot
more that people
have pursued with this model.
And it's also a connection
into the cryptography field,
which also makes use of the
interactive proof system model.
In fact, some of the
genesis of that model
comes out of
cryptography where you're
having multiple parties either
communicating or, in some ways,
interacting to achieve
certain goals of communication
or signing or passwords
or what have you.
So this is both an
applied area and also
one that has a lot of very
interesting theory associated
to it.
So with that, why
don't we-- we're
going to jump in and start
out by making myself smaller
and just do an introduction.
I'm going to introduce
the model or the concept
of an interactive
proof with an example,
and that example involves the
graph isomorphism problem.
That's the problem of testing
whether two graphs are
isomorphic.
What do we mean by two
graphs being isomorphic
is that they're really just
the same graph with one of them
perhaps being relabeled or
permuted so that they may look
superficially different,
they may appear
with a different
sequence of labels,
or the nodes are appearing
in a different order,
but except for that, it's
really just the same graph.
So I'm kind of illustrating that
here if you can see those two
graphs here, which look
different from each other.
Both on 8 nodes.
They are, in fact,
the same graph
as I can illustrate by a
little animation which will
convert this one into that one.
So the two graphs, these
graphs being the same,
we call that isomorphic.
So these are graphs G and H, and
they're really the same graph.
So we called them
isomorphic graphs,
and we have an associated
computational problem called
ISO, which is given a pair
of graphs, we'd like to know,
are they isomorphic or not?
So ISO is the
collection of pairs
of graphs which are isomorphic.
And it's easy to see that
this problem is an NP
problem because all you need to
do in order to see or to give
a certificate that
the two graphs are
isomorphic to each
other is tell you--
it's just to say which
nodes in the one graph
correspond to which other
nodes in the other graph.
And then you all
you'll need to check
is that the edge
relationships are
consistent with that
mapping or that isomorphism,
as it's called.
So it's easy to see that
the ISO problem is an NP.
And if you're not
getting that, make
sure you understand because the
whole first part of the lecture
will be lost if you don't
understand this ISO problem.
Now, the question
of whether you can
test two graphs being
isomorphic in polynomial time
is not clear.
And in fact, that's an
unsolved problem to this day.
And it's a problem
that has generated
an enormous literature.
There are hundreds of papers on
the graph isomorphism problem,
as it's called, to
try to resolve--
to try to see if one can find
a polynomial time algorithm.
And in fact, it was a very
big result just in the last 10
years where there was
subexponential algorithm given,
so that was more faster than
the brute force search approach
but didn't get it all the
way down to polynomial.
Now, why is there so
much attention just
to this one
particular NP problem?
It's because it's not known
whether the graph isomorphism
problem is NP complete.
ISO is not known to be
an NP complete problem,
and that puts it into a
very, very small class
of problems in NP
which are not known
to be either NP or NP complete.
It's kind of a curiosity
that for NP problems,
almost all of them have ended up
being in one side or the other.
And in fact, it's a--
in fact, I think it's
the only problem that
just involves graphs
that's not known
to be either in P or an NP.
So I got a question here.
What would be in between
exponential and polynomial?
For example, I don't
remember what the bound is,
but it's something in the
range of n to the log n,
a time complexity for
the graph isomorphism.
I may be getting that wrong.
I don't remember exactly
what the bound is.
But that's significantly
better than 2
to the n or some
exponential amount of time,
but it's more than
n to any constant,
so it's more than
any polynomial time.
So another question
of the same sort
is whether the complementary
problem is an NP
or whether ISO is
in coNP, or let's
talk about it in terms
of the complement,
whether the complement
of ISO, which I'll
refer to as the non-ISO
problem, whether that's
known to be an NP.
So that's also not known.
In other words, if I
give you two graphs
and I ask you to show that
they're not isomorphic,
suppose they aren't
isomorphic and you
go through the effort
of determining that
by a brute force
search and now you
want to prove that
they're not isomorphic,
well, it's not known
to be an NP either.
So there's no known short
certificate of two graphs
not being isomorphic.
We don't know how
to do that either.
But there's something that's
very interesting, nevertheless,
and it has to do with
the ability for one party
to prove to another that graphs
are either isomorphic or not
isomorphic.
So if you're just
having it like a prover,
we haven't really
been necessarily
formulating that this way
so much in this class,
but this is a completely
equivalent way
of formulating the
notion of NP whether you
have a polynomial time
verifier and a prover who
can produce certificates.
Say it's a powerful prover.
So if you have a
problem that's in NP,
a prover can convince a
polynomial time verifier
that strings are in the
language if in fact they are.
So in the case of
the ISO problem,
a prover can convince a
polynomial time verifier
that graphs are isomorphic just
by exhibiting the isomorphism.
Now, for the
non-isomorphism case,
we don't know that
that problem is in NP,
but it's still
possible for a prover
to convince a verifier that
graphs are not isomorphic
if you change the rules
of the game slightly.
So even though the
non-ISO problem is not
known to be an NP,
a prover can still
convince a polynomial
time verifier
that graphs are not
isomorphic, assuming
they are, in fact,
not isomorphic,
provided the prover
and the verifier
can interact with one another.
So the verifier can ask
questions of the prover,
and the verifier gets
to be probabilistic.
So that's in this--
that's in a sense
in which I mean
that this notion is a kind of
a probabilistic version of NP.
OK.
So let me show you
how that's done.
So before we jump in to
the method for a prover
to show a verifier that
graphs are not isomorphic,
let's try to get a little
clearer on the model.
So I'm going to first
show it to you informally,
and then we'll look
at it formally.
OK.
So in interactive proofs,
there are two parties.
And I'm going to think
about them as one of them
is going to be the professor.
So the professor is going to
play the role of the verifier,
in a sense, but it's
like the one who checks.
And the professor, being kind of
old and tired and teaching too
long maybe, can only operate in
probabilistic polynomial time.
So the professor, if he wants
to tell whether two graphs are
isomorphic or not,
probabilistic polynomial time
doesn't seem to be enough to
tell whether two graphs are
isomorphic or not
because it seems to be
a more than polynomial problem.
However, the professor has help.
It has an army of
graduate students,
and the graduate
students, they're
not limited in the same
way the professor is.
The graduate students are young.
They are energetic.
They can stay up all night.
They know how to code.
So the graduate students
have unlimited computational
ability.
So then we're going to think of
the graduate students playing
the role of the prover
because they're not
limited in their
capabilities, we'll assume.
The professor, on the
other hand, is limited.
So the professor wants
to know if the two
graphs are isomorphic, let's
say, whatever they are.
Can't do it by
himself, so he's going
to ask his students to figure
out the answer and report back.
Now, there's only one problem.
The professor knows
that students--
well, in the old days,
they'd like to party.
I guess these days, they like
to play computer games a lot.
And so they're not really that
eager to spend all their time
figuring out whether
graphs are isomorphic.
So he's worried that
the students will just
come up with some answer
and figure that he won't
be able to tell the difference.
So the professor does
not trust the students.
It's not enough
for the professor
to give the problem
to the students
and just take any answer
that they're going to give.
The professor wants
to be convinced.
So now, how could the students
convince the professor
of the answer, that they've
really done the work
and figured out whether the
graphs are isomorphic or not?
Well, if the graphs
are isomorphic,
if it turns out that the
graphs were isomorphic
and the students
figure that out,
then life is good
because what are they
going to do to
convince the professor?
They're going to hand
over the isomorphism
and show, yeah,
I mean, they are.
Those graphs really
are isomorphic,
and here's how the
correspondence works.
Professor can check, oh, yeah.
Now I'm convinced.
But suppose the graphs
were not isomorphic.
What are we going to do then?
The students have figured
out graphs are not isom--
the professor wants
to be convinced.
Oh, no.
What are we going to do?
Well, in fact, we're
going to engage--
the professor and
the students are
going to engage in the
following protocol.
Dialogue.
What's going to happen is--
now, you have to
make sure your--
this is critical to understand
this little part of the story
here because it's
really going to set
the pattern for everything
in today's and tomorr--
in today's lecture
and the next lecture.
So we're going to engage in
the following interaction
between the students
and the professor,
which is going to enable
the students to convince
the professor that the
two graphs really are not
isomorphic.
So how is that going to work?
This is a beautiful
little thing, by the way.
So the professor is going
to take the two graphs
and pick one of them at random.
Has these two graphs,
G and H. Let's
say they really
are not isomorphic.
The professor doesn't
know that for sure.
That's what the students claim.
The professor really
wants to be convinced
that the students are right.
So the professor's going to
pick one of the two at random.
Randomly permute
that choice, the one
that he picked, and hand
it over to the students.
Say, OK, here is one of those
two graphs randomly scrambled.
Then I'm going to ask the
students, which one did I pick?
Now, if the graphs were
really not isomorphic,
the students can check
whether that randomly
scrambled graph is
isomorphic to either G
or to H. It's going to be
isomorphic to one or the other.
And then the students
can figure it out,
and they say, oh you
picked G. Or no, you
picked H, as the case may be.
The students can
figure that out.
But if the graphs
were isomorphic,
then that scrambled
version of G or H
could equally well have
come from either of them.
And the students
would have no way
of knowing which one
the professor picked.
So there's nothing
they could do which
would be better than guessing.
So if we do that a bunch
of times, the professor
picks at random, sometimes
go secretly of course,
picks either G or picks
H and the students get it
right every time,
either the students
are really doing the work
and the graphs are really
not isomorphic or the students
are just incredibly lucky.
They're managing to guess
right, let's say, 100 times.
So how would the stu--
the professor randomly
and secretly picks G or H,
uses its probablism.
Flips a coin.
Just a two-sided coin.
Says, OK, sometimes
I'm going to do G,
sometimes I'm going to do H.
Just completely at random picks
one or the other.
Then with some more
randomness, finds
a random permutation of the
one that he picked and then
sends that over to
the students and say,
which one did it come from?
So I'm not sure--
OK, so let's pause here.
Let's make sure we all
understand this because this
is really important.
So I'm getting a question here.
How do we-- I'm not sure
what your question is.
OK, so let me just say the
professor is going to play
the role of the verifier.
The graduate students
play the role
of the prover that's
coming, but I really
want to understand
this protocol here.
OK.
So how is the professor
picking the graphs again?
OK, I don't-- picking
the graphs at random.
You have just two graphs.
They're part of the input.
Both the students and the
professor can see the graphs,
and the professor's
just picking one of them
at random using a coin.
So I'm not sure I understand
the question there.
Could P and V
engage in a protocol
where the secret here is
on the prover side instead?
The question of revealing the
isomorphism-- there is no iso--
I'm not sure I understand
this question either.
Maybe we'll make this clear--
for this little illustration,
the professor doesn't know.
The graphs could be
isomorphic or they
could be not isomorphic.
And so the professor wants to be
convinced either way, whatever
the students-- whatever answer
the students come up with.
We're going to shift
this into a problem
about deciding a language next.
But right now, I'm
just trying to give
a sense of how the model works.
I want to move from
this informal model,
and now I'm going to formalize
that in terms of model
which will be
deciding a language.
OK?
So the interactive
proof system model,
we have two interacting
parties, a verifier, which
is probabilistic
polynomial time,
played by the professor
in the previous slide,
and the prover, which is
unlimited computational power,
played by the students
in the previous slide.
Both of them get to
see the input, which
in the previous case,
well, it could be,
for example, the pair of graphs.
The exchange of number of
polynomial-size messages.
So the whole exchange, including
the verifier's own computation,
is going to be polynomial.
The only thing
that's not included
within the computational
cost is the prover's work,
which is unlimited.
After that, the verifier--
after the interaction,
the verifier will
accept or reject.
And we're going to
define the probability
that the verifier, together
with a particular prover,
ends up accepting as you look
over the different possible
coin tosses of the
verifier, which could lead
to different behavior on
the part of the verifier
and therefore,
different behavior
on the part of the prover.
So over all the
different possibilities
for the verifier's
computation, we're
going to look at the
probability that the verifier
with this particular
prover ends up accepting.
And I've written it this way.
It says the probability of
the verifier interacting
with the prover
accepts the input.
It's just simply that.
And so we're going to
work through an example.
We're going to work through
the previous example more
precisely in a second.
The class IP for
Interactive Proofs
stands for-- it's a
class of languages
such that for some
verifier and a prover,
for strings in the
language, the prover
makes the verifier accept
with high probability.
And here is the
interesting part.
For strings not in the
language, the prover
makes it accept with
low probability,
but there's no prover
which can make it
accept with high probability.
So there's no way to cheat.
If you think about it
in the case of the graph
non-isomorphism, if the
graphs were really isomorphic
and the students were
trying to, in a devious way,
prove through that protocol
that they're not isomorphic,
they would fail because
there's nothing they can do.
If the graphs were
isomorphic, then when
the verifier, or the professor,
picks one or the other
at random and scrambles
it, the students
would have no way of telling
which one the professor did.
So no matter what kind of
scheme they try to come up with,
they're going to be out of luck.
So it's no ma--
for any strategy,
for strings that are not in
the language, for any prover--
calling that P with
a tilde to stand
for a devious or crooked prover.
For any possibly crooked
prover, even that
would be working with
the verifier is still
going to end up accepting
with low probability.
So strings in the
language, there's
going to be an honest
prover who just follows
the protocol in the correct way,
which makes the verifier accept
with high probability.
For strings not in the
language, every prover
is going to fail to make it
accept with high probability.
OK.
So I mean, the way
I like to think
about it is that P tilde is a
possibly crooked prover which
is trying to make the verifier
accept when it shouldn't
because the string is
not in the language.
It's like you can think of this
in the case of satisfiability.
A crooked prover might try
to convince the verifier
that the formula's satisfiable
when it isn't by somehow trying
to produce a
satisfying assignment,
but that's going
to be impossible.
There's nothing any
strategy can possibly
work when the formula
is not satisfiable
if that's what the
verifier is going to check.
It's going to be looking for
that satisfying assignment.
OK?
And by the way, we're
not going to prove this,
but it's really going to
be proved in the same way.
You can make that
one third error
that occurs here,
something very tiny,
by the same kind of
repetition argument.
OK?
So let's see.
So why can't the prover in
the first case be crooked?
The prover in the first
case could be crooked,
but that's not going
to serve the purposes.
What we want to show--
think about it like
we think about NP.
For strings in the language,
there exists a certificate.
There is a proof that
you're in the language.
So if somebody is going
to not produce the proof,
that's irrelevant.
The question is, if
you look at the best
possible case, the best possible
prover who's going to be able--
we're asking, does
there exist a way
to convince the verifier that
the string is in the language?
So it doesn't matter that there
might be some other silly way
that doesn't work.
We just were looking at
the best possible way.
So the best possible way
when you're in the language
is going to end up with
the verifier having
high probability.
When you're not in the
language, the best possible way
is still going to end
up with low probability.
When I talk about
best possible, I'm
trying to maximize the
probability that the verifier
is going to end up accepting.
Let's continue.
Not sure I was as
clear as I would like,
but maybe again we're going
to stick with that example
because this is a
very helpful example
to try to understand the setup.
And so we're going to--
I'm going to revisit
that previous example
about non-isomorphism but now
in the context of this thinking
about it as a language.
So we're going to take
this non-isomorphism--
yeah.
We're going to take the
non-isomorphism problem
and show that it's an IP.
So there's going to
be a verifier together
with a prover, which are going
to make the verifier accept
with high probability for
strings in the language, namely
graphs not being isomorphic,
and nothing that's
going to be no way to
make the verifier accept
with high probability for
strings out of the language.
Therefore, that's when
the graphs are isomorphic.
OK.
So the protocol is just
we're going to repeat
the following thing twice.
You know, I said in the previous
case do it 100 times just
to help us to think about
it, but actually, twice
is going to be enough to
get the bound we need.
So the verifier is
going to operate
like this, in terms of
this is the verifier's
first communicating, sending
messages to the prover.
It's going to randomly
choose G or H, just
like what the professor
did last time,
randomly permute the result
to get a new graph, K,
which was going to be--
which is isomorphic either to G
or H depending upon the choice
the verifier made, and
then send that graph K.
Now, the prover's turn
is going to respond by--
the prover's going to
compare K with both
of the original graphs.
It's got to be isomorphic
to one or the other.
And it's going to
report back which one.
Just going to say,
well, you picked G. No.
Or you picked H.
Because the prover, with
its unlimited capabilities,
can determine that.
And then V accepts if the
prover was right both times.
And if the prover
was ever not right,
the verifier says, oh,
something's fishy here.
Because we know that the prover
has unlimited capability,
so could get it right if
this was an honest prover.
And so if it's not
getting it right,
then the verifier
is going to reject.
So if the graphs
are not isomorphic,
the prover can tell which
one it picked randomly.
So therefore, if the
graphs are not isomorphic,
the verifier with
that honest prover
will accept with probability
1 because that honest prover
is always going to get the right
answer, which is at least 2/3,
is the bound we need.
We don't care about the space
used, in answer to a question.
If we were not in the language,
so G and H are not isomorphic,
then there's nothing any
crooked prover could possibly
do because it gets a graph.
Can't tell.
There's no way to tell
whether it came from G
or came from H. So that
crooked prover would have o--
the best thing it
could do is guess.
So a 50% chance of answering
correctly each time and only
a 25% chance for doing it twice.
And that's why I did
it twice, in order
to get that error to be small.
So it's only a 25% chance
of the prover getting lucky,
so that would be an error case
if the prover, just by chance,
picked the right answer twice,
even though the graphs were
isomorphic.
So therefore, for
the isomorphic case,
the verifier interacting
with any prover
is going to accept that
input with, at most,
one quarter, 25% of the time,
which is less than a third.
So that's just to
achieve that bound.
OK?
So let's answer some questions
first, and then I'll try to--
I'll ask you.
You understand this?
So I think it's worth
trying to understand
this model of this
interactive proof system.
It's a little
slippery, I realize,
but if you just hold onto your
intuition of the prover trying
to convince--
a powerful prover
trying to convince
a limited verifier of some
string being in a language.
You want the prover to be able
to succeed when the string is
in the language but fail
when the string is not
in the language.
Yes.
We are going to--
somebody's asking
if the prover is identifying
G or H by brute force.
Yes.
The prover is going to use
its unlimited capabilities
to determine, given K,
whether it came from G or H.
The computational cost of the
prover is irrelevant for this.
It's just like when we
think about a certificate
for satisfiability.
We don't talk about
the cost of finding
that certificate for NP.
For IP, again, we don't talk
about the cost of the prover
running.
So somebody is asking,
does the crooked prover
answer just randomly, or can the
crooked prover have a strategy?
The crooked prover
can have a strategy.
We're assuming the
crooked prover is devious.
But it's still going to fail.
OK.
Let's do the check-in.
Suppose we change the model
so that the prover can
watch the verifier picking
its random choices.
So the verifier cannot
act in secret anymore,
but the prover can
watch the verifier.
Now, let's suppose we
had the same protocol
that I just described.
What language do we end up with?
Is it the same language,
different language,
and what is that language?
So going to hopefully--
it'll give me some sense of
how well you're following me
by how well this goes.
Yeah, someone's asking about how
this connects up, for example,
with NP.
So we're going to look
at that also in a second.
OK, so this is reassuring
that most of you, I think,
are on the right track, at
least for this check-in.
Do we assume P uses this
access to guess right?
What access?
P is not really guessing.
The P is actually--
I don't think a P is
non-deterministic or anything
like that.
P is actually trying
to get the right answer
and using its
computational ability
to do that if it's possible.
It may not be possible.
Then there's nothing you can do.
OK, so let's end this.
Are you all in?
Two seconds left.
Please vote.
Vote now or never.
OK, ending.
Yeah, so C is the
correct answer here.
If the prover can watch
what the verifier is doing,
the prover can see what graph
the verifier picked right
from the beginning.
And so the prover, without
having to do any work,
can say--
prover looks over the
verifier's shoulder and says,
oh, you pick G. And now
you're randomly permuting it,
but I don't care about that.
I know you pick G, so the prover
is going to respond back a G.
Even if the graphs
were isomorphic,
the prover is going to be
able to get the right answer.
Kind of interestingly,
you can make
a-- you can change
the protocol somewhat
to make it that even if
the prover has access
to the verifier's randomness,
you can still achieve this,
but not with the same protocol.
So that's a separate question.
OK, so let's move on here.
Don't want to get
too bogged down.
OK, here's another check-in.
OK, so you have
to tell me, which
of the following
statements are true?
As far as you know.
You'll have to think a little
bit how these relate to--
how NP and IP or BPP and
IP relate to one another.
OK, how are we doing on this?
So we're going to have to
close this pretty soon too.
Do the best you can.
Interesting.
OK.
Closing up shop.
Last vote.
OK, 1, 2, 3.
There's one more
person out there
who hasn't voted
who voted last time.
Oh well.
All right.
In fact, they're all true.
Let's see.
Why is NP contained with
IP, contained in IP?
Well, many of you have
seen this already,
so let's just quickly
go through it.
If we just had a deterministic
V, maybe it's just--
is that going to be enough
if deterministic V--
I think it's just
going to be equivalent,
but actually, just
to be doubly sure,
the deterministic
V and the prover
just sends a message to the
verifier and then checks it.
That's the way we normally think
about a certificate for NP.
I don't think it's going
to change anything,
but should double-check that,
if the verifier can still
ask questions.
But I think as long as the
verifier is deterministic,
you're going to get
exactly NP here.
And now, how about BPP?
Well, there you don't
even need a prover
because the verifier is
already probabilistic.
So verifier can
ignore the prover.
And this one is a little
tricky, IP contained in PSPACE,
because we haven't covered that.
So there's no way for you to
know that unless you happened
to read ahead in the book.
But it's, in fact, true.
In some ways, it's a
little bit like the proof
that NP is contained in PSPACE.
IP is sort of an
enhanced version of NP.
And there's just basically
a piece-based brute force
algorithm that goes through the
entire tree of possibilities
of the verifier and verifier
with exchanges with the prover
and can determine that
the verifier is either
going to accept for some
prover or is going to end up
rejecting for every prover.
So we're not going to prove
this statement, but something
good for you to know
anyway, just the fact.
But we're going to do--
the surprising thing,
in reference to part C,
is that the containment
also goes the other way.
This is the amazing--
is an amazing result,
that everything in PSPACE
you can do within IP.
So this is-- IP actually turns
out to be incredibly powerful.
Gives you everything in PSPACE.
You get IP equals PSPACE.
So that says that any problem
that you can solve in PSPACE,
like any of the-- a
game, for example.
If you can imagine
formulating checkers or chess
as a PSPACE problem,
which depending
upon some details
of the rules you
can do because you have
to generalize it to an n
by n board, but OK.
Let's not quibble.
Then we don't know which side
has a forced win in chess,
and even if somebody goes
to the effort of going
through the game
tree and determines
that, let's say, white
has a forced win,
there's no way for them to--
there's no short certificate.
We don't know that that
problem is not an NP.
But by going through
an interactive proof,
an all-powerful prover could
still convince somebody that
white had a forced--
convince somebody
in polynomial time
that a white has a forced
win, let's say, in chess.
Again, a little stretching
things because this is--
you really need to talk about
this as an n by n, not an 8
by 8, but I think
the spirit is fair.
So OK.
So let's continue.
So we're not going
to quite prove
that PSPACE is contained in IP.
We're going to prove a
somewhat weaker statement,
but very similar and
historically came first,
that coNP is contained in IP.
So not only is NP
contained in IP,
but we're going to prove
that coNP is contained in IP.
And this actually has most of
the idea for the PSPACE being
contained in IP.
And itself, it's just
an amazing proof.
A little easier.
OK.
This was done, if I'm
remembering-- somebody's
asking me, how old is this?
It's something in the, I
think, late '90s, but I'm not--
I don't remember.
Maybe early '90s.
I think it's late '90s
when this was shown,
so it's been a while now.
OK.
So yeah.
So in terms of the
relationship with cryptography,
there were two parallel
threads that both independently
came up with the notion of
an interactive proof system.
I was a little bit
personally involved with this
in a way as well,
but mainly that there
was one group in
cryptography working on this,
and there was another
group who was actually
coming out of the graph
isomorphism world,
working on it.
And they came up with
two separate models,
one involving the private
randomness and one involving
the public randomness.
And it was turned out that
they were actually equivalent.
And it's an interesting
story, but unfortunately, we
don't have time for it.
So why don't we move on.
And I'm going to
start showing you
how the proof that coNP
is contained in IP goes.
And what we're
going to do is work
with a problem that's almost
like coNP complete, but going
to be--
well, it's going to
be this #SAT problem.
We'll see the connection
with coNP in a second.
So coNP, so it's supposed
to be exactly k satisfying
assignments.
Phi comma k is a
set of pairs where
the formula phi has exactly
k satisfying assignment.
So really, this is a
problem of counting
how many satisfying assignments
you have in a formula.
So for NP, you
have at least one.
But I want to know
exactly how many.
So the #SAT problem is the
pair's formula and the count.
And so if we define
the count, #phi
is the number of satisfying
assignments of a phi.
Then in another way of
writing this #SAT problem
is the pair's phi k where k
is the number of satisfying
assignments of phi.
So we're going to be using
this notation #phi a lot,
so just make sure you
got that notation.
This is the number of satisfying
assignments of that formula.
OK?
And here's a
definition I probably
should have given you
earlier in the term,
but better late than never.
So the notion that a
language is NP hard,
it's like NP complete except
without being necess--
without necessarily being in NP.
So this is just
the reduction part.
A language is NP hard or
coNP hard or PSPACE hard
or any of those other
classes that we've
looked at if every
problem in the class
is reducible to that language.
But you don't know whether
that language is in the class.
So we just call it NP hard
instead of NP complete.
So you could say the language
is NP complete if it's hard
and it's in NP.
OK, and so we're going to
show that this #SAT problem is
coNP hard.
So everything in coNP is
polynomial time reducible
to #SAT.
That's easy because
what we're going to do
is take a coNP
complete problem, which
is the unsatisfiability
problem, the complement
of satisfiability, and show that
reduces to the #SAT problem.
And that's easy because a
formula is unsatisfiable
exactly when it has zero
satisfying assignments.
So if you can tell how
many satisfying assignments
something has exactly, or
you can answer the question,
does a formula have exactly
1,000 satisfying assignments,
if you can do that in general,
then you can solve coNP.
You can solve the
unsatisfiability problem
by asking if it's zero
satisfying assignments,
and that allows you to
solve anything in coNP.
OK.
So we're going to just
work with this one
problem, the #SAT problem, and
show that that problem's in IP.
OK?
Let's take a quick break.
OK.
Feel free to send
me-- let me see
if I can catch up with
some of the questions that
have been cropping up here.
So if the prover knows the
random choices of the verifier,
can flip the answer to
make the verifier reject?
Not sure what that-- you mean
in the context just of the graph
isomorphism problem or
something in general?
I'm not sure I--
you'll have to explain.
So I will respond
with a question mark.
What else can I
answer for you guys?
So I've got a question.
If IP equals PSPACE, does that
mean that ISO or non-ISO might
be N, might be PSPACE complete?
But no.
That's not known.
So we're about out of time.
OK.
Let's continue here.
OK, so this is
where we're kind of
going to start to get
into the meat of things.
And if you didn't quite
understand everything up
till now, maybe just try
to keep your intuition
about how does a
powerful party convince
a probabilistic polynomial
time party of the number
of satisfying assignments?
An exact number.
Not at least, but you
want to know exactly
the number of
satisfying assignments.
So it could be
zero, for example.
How do you convince a--
how do you convince someone that
there were zero assignments?
And you can have an
interaction which does that,
and that's not obvious at all
how you're going to do that.
All right.
So OK.
So we're going to have to
introduce some notation, which
I hope that it doesn't
cause heartburn here.
So let's say, again,
here is the language
we're working with, #SAT.
And we have a phi that
has m variables, x1 to xm.
Now, here's the notation.
I'm going to-- if I
write phi with a--
phi of 0, that just
means the formula
that I get by
plugging in 0 for x1
and leaving all the rest
of the variables alone.
OK, so I substitute 0 for x1
where 0 means false and 1 means
true as usual.
And but it's still going
to be some other formula
but just with that substitution.
If I write phi 01, that means
I've preset the first two
variables to 0 and 1.
If I write phi with a
bunch of preset values,
I'm just setting the first
i variables, x1 to xi,
to some values and leaving
the other variables as unset.
So I'm calling the
ones that I'm nailing
in there, as I'm already
saying, these are the presets.
So this is just
converting some formulas
into other formulas that have
somewhat fewer variables.
All right?
Now, let's recall that number
notation and number sign
notation, #phi is the number
of satisfying assignments.
Now, if I say #phi of
0, that's the number
of satisfying assignments
when I've preset x1 to 0.
Similarly, if I preset the first
i variables to some values and
then I take--
I want to take how
many satisfying
assignments subject to those
presets, I write it this way.
So I'm going to use
this notation a lot.
You have to understand
this notation.
Ask if you don't un--
if you don't get it.
So another way of writing it--
I don't know if this is
helpful, but another way
of writing #phi of a1
to ai, remember, we
have m variables
altogether, that means
I take the variables which
I have not yet preset,
and I allow them to range
of all possible 0s and 1s,
and I add up the formula's
values for all of those.
So there's a 1 every time I
satisfy and a 0 every time I
don't satisfy.
So I'm adding up all the
satisfying assignments subject
to these i presets.
OK?
So here are two critical
facts about this number sign
notation.
First of all, if I preset the
first i values to something,
now I can, in addition,
set the next variable
either to 0 or to 1, and
I get this relationship,
which is just simply a
generalization of the fact
that the total number of
satisfying assignments
of the formula is equal to
the number of satisfying
assignments when x1 is 0
plus the number of satisfying
assignments when x1 is 1.
They together have to add
up to the total number
because x1 is going
to be either 0 or 1.
So that's fact number one.
Fact number two is that
if I preset everything,
all of the variables, so
there are no variables
left, then the number of
satisfying assignments
subject to that
preset of everything
is just whether or
not I've satisfied
the formula, which is
the value of the formula
on those presets.
OK?
Both two simple
facts, but it's going
to be critical in the protocol
I'm about to describe.
Questions on this?
I think I actually do
have a question for you.
So let's just see.
What do you think?
It's just to check
your understanding.
OK.
Got about 80% getting this.
I'm not sure that's good.
But all right.
Almost done?
Closing.
OK.
OK, so yes.
A is the correct answer.
If there are 9 satisfying
assignments all together
and there are 6
satisfying assignments
with the first
variable is set to 0,
then there's only 3
satisfying assignments
with the first variable
set to 1 because 9 has
got to be equal to 6 plus 3.
That's actually this
fact number one.
It's not going to be 15.
This is not true either.
So it's just A. Good.
OK.
OK, so let's try to--
with that knowledge,
let's try to see
how we can put #SAT in IP.
So this is not
going to quite work,
but it's really
going to set us up
to do this-- to
finish this next time.
So you might immediately see
where this is going wrong,
but you'll have to put up
with it because the setup is
what's important.
OK.
So understand, now,
here's the setup.
We have the input is
a formula and a number
where that number is supposed
to be the number of satisfying
assignments.
It could be wrong,
in which case,
we're not in the language.
But if it's right,
you're in the language.
So the prover is supposed to
convince the verifier that it's
correct if it is correct.
And it's not going
to-- it's going
to fail no matter what it tries
to do if it's not correct.
So this says the prover is
going to send, first of all--
so the prover is going to
send a claim about the number
of satisfying assignments.
Going to send-- when
I say this value here,
this is what the prover--
if it's honest, it's going
to send the right value.
Of course, the verifier does not
know if the prover is honest,
but I'm describing how
the honest prover is
going to operate.
And we'll have to
understand what happens
if the prover tries to cheat.
So the prover is going to send--
the honest prover is going
to send the number of satisfying
assignments altogether,
and the verifier just makes
sure that that matches up
with the input.
If it doesn't match
up with the input,
the verifier is just going to--
the verifier is going to not
be convinced that the input is
in the language.
So it's going to just
reject at that point.
OK.
Then now the verifier says, OK.
That was very good
that you sent me this.
How do I know that's right?
So what the prover
is going to do
to try to convince the
verifier that this value was
correct is unravel that
by one level by say,
well, there were 9 satisfying
assignments altogether.
6 them were when x1 is 0, and
3 of them were when x1 is 1.
What does the verifier
have to check?
That these add up correctly.
When I preset x1
to 0 and to 1, it
had better add up
to the total number
of satisfying assignments.
If that works out,
the verifier's happy.
It's still being-- it's
still consistent with being
convinced that this k
was the right value.
So the next step is, well,
the verifier says, well,
how do I know those
two values are correct?
The prover says, OK.
Well, I want to unravel them one
level further then the number
of satisfying assignments
when the next variable is
set to both
possibilities for each
of the possibilities
of the first variable.
Now, if you're understanding
me about what the prover is
sending, you should start to
be getting a little nervous
because something is--
I mean, this is
going to be correct,
but it's going to start--
it looks like it's starting
to blow up in terms of the
amount of work that's involved,
and that's actually a problem.
But let's bear with
that for the moment.
Let's just worry about
correctness, not about
complexity for the moment.
So the prover's
going to now send
the number of satisfying
assignments for each
of those four possible ways
of presetting the first two
variables, and the
verifier is going
to check that that was
consistent with the information
the prover sent in
the previous round
by, again, checking
this identity here.
So then the prover's
going to continue
doing that until it's done
that through m rounds, where
m is the number of variables.
So at this point,
the prover's going
to send all possible
ways of presetting
all of the variables.
So now there's 2 to the
m possibilities here.
Again, this is hopelessly not
allowed, but OK, ignoring that.
The prover's got to use
this at the nth round
to check what happens
at the previous round,
so that's when they were
m minus 1 values sent
because each one has one more--
you're extending
the presets by 1.
So we're using this to check
that the previous round
values were correct.
So it's looking for--
the m minus 1 presets
have to add up correctly
in terms of the
presets of m values
for each of those ways of
doing those m minus 1 presets.
And so now, the prover
has sent all of those 2
to the m counts,
which are, by the way,
1s and 0s because at this
point, we have preset all
of the values of the variables.
And so there's only
one possible assignment
at most that there can be.
And now the prover is done.
The verifier is going
to check by itself
that these values make sense,
that these values are correct.
So it's going to do that by
looking back at the formula.
So far, up until this
point, the verifier
has not been looking
at the formula.
It's just been checking
the internal consistency
of the prover's messages
with each other.
But now at the end,
the verifier is
going to take these values
that the prover sent
for each of the 2
to the m presets
and see if it matches up with
what the formula would do.
Remember, that was the other--
sort of the base case
of the fact number
two from the slide or two ago.
Make sure that these agree.
OK, and now the
verifier says, well, OK.
If everything has checked
out and all of these
are in agreement,
then the verifier
is going to be
convinced that phi
had k satisfying assignments.
But if anywhere along the way
one of these checks fails,
the prover is not-- the verifier
is not going to be convinced,
and it's going to reject.
So in a sense, this
is kind of dopey.
I mean, I'm just kind of giving
you a complicated way of just
counting up, one by one, each
of the satisfying assignments
of the formula and
seeing if that matches k.
But nevertheless, this
way of looking at it
is going to help us to
understand the way to fix this.
So bear with me for
another minute on this one.
So another way of
looking at this,
which I think is
particularly useful,
is to think of what happens--
well, OK.
We'll get there in a second.
I want to look at what
happens if k was wrong,
but before I do that,
let's look at the--
I'm going to give a
kind of a graphical view
of the information that the
prover sends and the verifier's
actions in this protocol.
So the values that
the prover's sending
are going to be in yellow.
So and the information that
the verifier has or checks
is going to be in white.
So the verifier has
the k, the input value,
which is supposed to be
the number of satisfying
assignments, and the
prover sends some value,
and the verifier checks
that this value, which
is supposed to be the number
of satisfying assignments,
corresponds with k.
So that's one of
the checks it does.
Then the prover
is going to send--
going to take, to
justify this value,
it sends the number of
satisfying assignments when you
have x1 set to 0 or set to 1.
The verifier adds
those up to give you--
and it's supposed to
equal the total number
of satisfying assignments.
And so this is-- if you
understood this protocol,
this is just--
I'm writing it out in a sort
of a simplified way perhaps.
OK.
And so keeps checking
that these things add up
correctly until you get down to
setting all m values in all 2
to the m possible ways,
and now the verifier
is going to then check to
make sure that that equals
what the formula would say.
OK.
So now, what happens if
k was the wrong value?
It did not agree with the number
of satisfying assignments.
And what happens now?
Could the prover-- what happens
if the prover tries to make
the verifier accept anyway?
So the only thing the prover
can do at the very first step
would be to lie about--
if the prover sends
the-- if k is wrong
and the prover sends the correct
value for the total count,
the verifier's going to reject.
So I'm trying to
see, could the prover
try to make the verifier accept?
What happens?
So the prover has
to lie here, and I'm
going to indicate that
by saying the prover is
sending in the wrong
value for the total count.
Well, if the prover's
going to lie here,
then just like if you have
a child who tells a lie,
and then you start--
as the parent,
you start asking
questions to try
to see if the story
is consistent,
one lie is going to
lead to another lie.
And that's what happens here.
In order to justify
this lie, the prover
is going to have to lie
in one, or perhaps both,
but at least one
of these two values
because you can't have the
two correct values adding up
to the incorrect value.
So you have to think about
what's going on here.
So this is a lie
that's going to force
a lie at one side or the
other one level down,
which is then going to force
a lie to propagate down.
And so there's-- a lie at every
stage is going to force a lie
at least in one place or another
to propagate all the way down
to the bottom.
And then at the
bottom, the verifier
will see that the
check doesn't work
as when it tries to connect
it up with the formula itself,
and the verifier will reject.
So it's just a way
of looking at this.
If the for-- if the value--
if the input was
not in the language.
So but the problem is that, as
I said, this is exponential.
So how are we going to fix that?
So just looking ahead to what
we're going to do on Tuesday--
OK, let's see if there's any
questions here first of all.
OK.
I got a question.
Should this be--
should this be a minus?
I purposely made this bracket
not include the very last 0.
Yeah, there's a total
of m 0s here altogether,
but I left out the last 0.
That's why I said m minus 1.
Maybe it would have
been better to say m.
OK, so I've got another
interesting question here.
Why can't we reject
right away if k is wrong?
Well, the verifier is
probabilistic polynomial time.
How does the verifier
know if k is wrong?
So I mean-- or right.
So what we're trying to
do is something like NP
where we have a
certificate, but now we
have this kind of
interactive certificate
in the form of this prover.
Maybe that's another
way to look at it.
Where if you're in
the language, there
should be some way for the
prover to make you accept.
But if you're not
in the language,
there should be no way for
the prover to make you accept.
So the verifier just
can't reject right away
because there's no way to tell.
How does the verifier know?
It's going to start
rejecting things
when it shouldn't if it's
just going to be rejecting
willy-nilly here.
OK.
How does the verifier
need to determine
if the prover is internally
consistent instead
of just asking--
so why does the verifier
need to determine
if the prover is
internally consistent
instead of just asking the
questions in step n plus 1?
Yeah, so maybe that's--
because it looks
like all of the work
is happening at the very end.
But I'm really
presenting this to you
as a preparation for what
we're going to do on Tuesday.
So it's important to think about
the connection from each step
to the next.
Each step is going to
be justified by what
happens at the next step
until we get to the very end.
So you'd have to just
understand it for what it is.
Don't try to make
it more efficient.
I realize this is kind of dumb.
Good point.
We're not using the
probablism here.
And moreover, we're not really
even using the interaction
here.
The prover is doing
all the sending.
The verifier is just
accepting at the end.
Yeah.
We're not using the power, and
we're getting a weaker result.
So let's move on before
we run out of time here.
So how are we going to fix this?
So the problem is
this blowing up.
To justify each
stage, each value
we're needing to present two
values which add up to it.
And that's leading to a blowup.
Now, it would be nice
if we can do something
where each value was supported
by just a single value
at the next level.
So here's an idea.
In order to understand to
see that this total count is
correct, why don't we just
pick at random either 0 or 1
and only follow that one down?
Well, the problem
with doing that
is because the sequence of lies
could be just a single path
through this tree.
And the chances you're
going to find that path down
to a contradiction at
the bottom is very low
if you're just
doing it at random.
So just randomly
picking 0s and 1s
as the one you're
going to justify,
used to justify
the previous value,
is not going to be good enough.
But this is what
we're going to do.
However, the values
that we're going
to pick for these
random inputs are not
going to be Boolean values.
We're going to pick non-Boolean
assignments to the variables.
Which again, just as with
the branching program case,
didn't make any sense
on the surface of it.
We're going to have
to make it make sense.
And we'll have to see how to
do that in Tuesday's lecture.
So that's kind of the setup.
OK.
Yeah, so in a similar question.
Why is this any different from
just non-deterministically
guessing the assignments?
It's because of this.
We're really setting the stage.
OK.
So what we did today was
we introduced the model
and defined the
complexity class.
We did show this one
in its full glory.
We showed that non-ISO is an IP.
Really worth understanding
this protocol here, making sure
you're comfortable with that
and also the model itself.
And so for Tuesday's lecture,
we're going to finish this up.
Well, we started
showing that #SAT
is an IP which is what we need
to do to prove coNP is an IP.
And we'll finish that next time,
which will be our last time.
OK.
So that's it for today.
I'll stick around for questions.
So a good question here.
Why can't V just reject if some
of the checks are incorrect?
Yes.
As soon as there's
a check that fails,
V can just reject at that stage.
I'm just trying to argue that
at some point along the way,
if the input is not
in the language,
there's going to be
a check that fails.
I mean, I said reject
at the end, but yeah.
I mean, you could have rejected
at any point along the way.
OK.
Someone's asking for
what role did I play?
So I did-- my own personal
role in this was twofold.
First of all, I came
up with the idea of--
not the idea.
I came up with the
name interactive proof.
I remember when Silvio Micali
was explaining this to me
in my apartment
many, many years ago.
He had kind of a little
bit complicated--
and I don't even remember
what the protocol was for.
It was not for something simple.
It was something
involving prime numbers.
And I said, oh.
That's a kind of an
interactive proof.
And it stuck from that point on.
So that was one thing.
But the other thing, in
terms of more mathematically,
my role was-- so
Shafi Goldwasser and I
proved the equivalence of the
two models, the public coin
and the private coin version.
So that was my role
in this back when
this was all first coming out.
Proved it on an airplane on the
way to a conference somewhere.
Anyway, so I think
we're going to--
unless there's any
other questions,
I think we'll head out.
Take care, everybody.
See you on-- see you on Tuesday.
Bye-bye.